(exhaling)
- Okay, okay, don't panic, don't panic!
Oh my gosh I'm panicking!
What do I do? I'm out of toilet paper.
I have a poopy butt right now.
I have a poopy butt.
Get it together. Get it together.
What are we going to do?
Ahhh.
(crying)
I don't have anymore toilet paper.
Okay Zack, think, think.
There's napkins in the kitchen.
Pull up your pants, and
waddle to the kitchen
and get yourself some napkins.
You got this.
(dramatic orchestra music)
- Oh, hey Zack!
Hey, I want you to meet my friend Kelsey.
- Hi.
- Hey, how's it going?
I've heard so much about you.
Um, I would shake your
hand but I'm feeling
a little under the weather.
I'm sick right now, so (coughs)
- It's fine.
- Cool. I'll let you guys just be.
I'm going to be back in my bedroom.
Nice meeting you.
- Alright, cool. See you later.
- Nice to meet you.
(screaming)
- What am I going to do?
I'm out of toilet paper. Ah! Ah!
(crying)
(ding)